thank you everybody I'm very happy to be
here my name is Mike Garcia and I'm a
director of data services for medible
and today I want to talk about how you
can scale your data validation workflow
with the point blank r package and posit
connect 10 years ago I was a data
analyst for a very large utility company
in the country and one of my main
responsibilities was to create and
maintain these Energy savings
forecast and
I have a confession to make I really
didn't know what I was doing and I was
never confident in the numbers that I
was producing and that was because there
was no formal process for these
forecasting tasks and when it came time
to do our data validation to check our
work it involved a group of us um going
into a conference room throwing
everything up on a big screen and just
opening up Excel workbooks tracing
through cells and looking at where the
formulas
landed it was not a fun process today I
can confidently say that this is not how
my team operates at matal in fact we
have robust procedures for everything
that we do especially when it comes to
data validation and that's what I want
to talk about today by building upon our
foundation of data quality measures at
medible expanding the functionality of
the point blank r package and leveraging
posit connect with its API we were able
to design and Implement a fully endtoend
scalable solution for our data
validation needs and so for the next 15
minutes I want to highlight four
challenges that we came across and uh
how we address
them before we dive any deeper I'd like
to give a little bit of background about
medible so medible is a technology
startup uh with a state-of-the-art
platform for conducting clinical trials
our clients are some of the largest
Pharma companies and contract research
organ research organizations in the
world and we license our platform to
these clients in the form of web and
mobile apps that we build and deploy for
them as a service these apps are used by
patients and caregivers and doctors all
throughout their trial
participation and some of the activities
that they may do on these apps are
completing pain assessments on a weekly
basis or entering uh diary data every
day detailing their experiences with a
new investigational drug all of these
activities with the apps generate a lot
of data and that data gets stored
securely on the medible platform and
it's the job of my team in data services
at medable to transfer that data from
the platform to the hands of the
client but that's not as straightforward
as you would think because data models
between studies and projects vary and
that's primarily driven by three factors
one protocols just varying complexity
and design and so our apps sometimes
need to as well in order to accommodate
the needs uh second trials can last for
years but our technology moves a lot
faster than that so if we want to um
Implement bug fixes or introduce a new
capability sometimes we need to do that
on a study by- study basis and lastly
clients have very strict expectations on
what they want their data to look like
and how they want to receive that and
that's also driven by the fact that they
have these large systems in their
organization and so it's up to us to
work with them to make sure that they
can ingest the data that we're sending
to
them now all this flexibility meant that
our processes especially for data
validation had to be flexible but that
meant manual and for years ago that was
okay that worked well but as the number
of studies that we supported grew
exponentially we started to notice some
data quality issues creeping in into our
deliverables so late last year we made
this conscious effort to really
streamline and automate a lot of what we
were doing related to data validation
and that's when we stumbled upon the
point blank
package Point Blank allows you to
validate your data using these simple
yet powerful validation functions for
example if you wanted to test if a set
of values in a column less than equal to
another value or set of values in
another column there's a function for
that the way that it works is you create
what what is known as an agent object
you pass to it a single Target table
that you want to validate and some other
data like how you want to be alerted if
a test case would fail you then pass
this object to these validation
functions and these act as um sort of
instructions for what your agent should
do when it's ready to validate
and then when you are ready to validate
you call the interrogate function so in
essence you're interrogating the agent
for the information that you want and
the result is a really nice looking
easyto digest HTML report on the left
you have a nice color coding scheme that
tells you what passed what failed or if
you hit another threshold that you set
when creating your agent each record
represents a validation function that
you set and the columns next to it that
you um apply them to and on the right
you have some descriptive statistics
telling you how many cases were run for
each function how many passes and fails
and their
proportions and at first glance it was
perfect it was everything that we needed
the way that it integrated with packages
that we used already and Technologies
and also its intuitive API and its
source code was easy to to
digest however once we actually started
to implement it for our processes and
data we notic there were four specific
challenges that we had to address before
we could do that and that's what I'm
going to walk through right now so the
first challenge is we wanted point blank
to operate on more than just a single
Target
table here's an example of a data model
for our study for a very simple study
that we may see if we wanted to test
each individual table we would need to
create each individual agents and apply
them to the tables and that's at the
core of Point Blank and we didn't want
to change that for our needs instead we
wanted to bundle all of these agents
together into a collection that we can
then operate on that collection and so
in typical R fashion uh we wrapped
everything into a list and we applied
some processing to it that specific to
our needs and we called it a test plan
and so essentially it's a list of Agents
with some extra goodies that I'll talk
about in a little bit if you're familiar
with Point Blank this is very much like
a multi-agent report and we borrowed a
lot from that uh we're just extending
upon it to perform operations on that
actual multi-agent instead of it being
just a reporting function uh so in the
background this is very simple concept
but we uh modified uh lots of Point
Blank and pins functions to actually do
what we wanted to do with this and also
we integrated it with the DM package uh
which we use for our data modeling
needs so when we want to create a test
plan it's uh very straight forward you
pass in your individual agents and then
you pass to it also a test name which
you will we will reference later on and
some of the data that get stored with
the test plan are the name that we just
passed through as well as a test version
that we get from pins and connect and
I'll share very
briefly now when we're ready to validate
our collection of Agents or our test
plan we have to uh run interrogate on
each individual function so or each
individual agent so we basically map the
interrogate function to all the agents
uh and we also Force the user to
specifically pass in the data that
they're going to validate which is a
little different than how Point Blank
Works natively in my experience um but
it also prevents any scoping r that we
may encounter later while we're doing
some
sharing and the result is what's known
as a multi-agent report so well again we
borrow this we streamline the formatting
of of it a little bit for our needs and
we also uh did some things like
streamline the title of it so now at the
title we have our test name and we have
the test version for traceability
reasons the Second Challenge is we
wanted to implement sharing and
reusability of the test plans that our
team is creating
so I showed a simple data model before
but in reality they look more like this
and you can guess that if we're
validating each table uh the code the
point blank code to generate all that
can get pretty large and pretty um
unwieldy quickly so one feedback that we
heard from the team is how can we reuse
these uh test plans so that we're not
creating the recreating the wheel every
single time we start a new study or want
to iterate on an existing test plan so
copy and paste is an option but it's not
really a practical one in a production
setting so if we revisit our create test
plan function again we could do a little
more in it we could add some
functionality so we're going to take
each of the individual agents inside of
of this test plan and we're going to
actually extract the code that's needed
to create um that individual agent so
it's kind of like we're reverse
engineering that part and the the reason
for that is that we want to actually
store that code instead of the actual
object object the agent object itself on
connect so we're going to take that code
and we're going to convert it to Json
and we're going to write it to connect
as a pin and Json is because we want
full transparency for anyone who's not a
data scientist to be able to go on the
connect and look to see what's actually
going on with the
code now with posit connect if you have
a lot of content on there sometimes a
little hard to filter around so you can
set tags for easy filtering and
navigating so we set tags so that this
could be a test plan and by default when
you share um when you publish content to
connect it's just shared with yourself
You' have to go into the UI and and
change that so we actually use um posit
connect API to do that in the function
itself so then we share access with our
data team um by default here's a
screenshot of what that pin looks like
on connect uh so in typical fashion you
have your the time that was last updated
the format which is Json and a
streamlined um description for it and
then you you have your raw metadata
that's provided by pins and with pins
you're also able to pass in some
userdefined
metadata and so we hook up to that and
we include the name of the person that
last modified the test plan as well as a
commit message uh for that new version
of the plan so we want this to be more
act more like a a git based
system and if we expand upon that uh
object you're not supposed to read this
but what I want to show here it's actual
Json it's unformatted but it's still
Json and on the right in the Box um you
seeing that we're sharing it with our
internal data team
group so if we want to take this and
actually bring it back into our studio
and iterate on it or use it as a jumping
off point for the next uh project we
have a convenience function called view
test plan where all we do is supply the
test name and if not the latest version
the test version and what it does is in
your IDE opens up a new file pane dumps
all the code in there and it's ready for
you to modify as
needed the Third challenge was we wanted
to automate with posit connect because
we use it already for our study
deployments so um when you want to
automate something with r our markdown
is usually the answer or quto or Flex
dashboard and when you do that there's
also a lot of ways you can create that
document so we wanted to streamline that
part and so we created a function called
create validate that actually takes your
data and your test plan from connect and
it feeds it into a template that we've
created internally
uh so that it kind of streamlines that
so all you have to do is run this
function provide it your data and your
test name and you get um an R markdown
document that's ready to be
knit then with as we want to um automate
it we have to deploy it to connect we
can use the the great push button
deployment option but even still when
you do that there are some options that
you need to set that we take for granted
like do you want to lint your code uh do
you want to force an update if something
exists already um do you um do you have
all the dependencies ready those little
check boxes that show up so again we
wanted to just make it easy as possible
to do this in a production setting so we
created deploy validation which
essentially wraps the deploy doc
function from RS connect and similar to
creating a test plan we tag it we share
it with our data team and we uh set a
default schedule using the API to
run and what that looks like is a flex
dashboard with two tabs the first tab is
data and sources it includes all the
data that's needed to run and execute
this test plan so that includes the
target table references as well as any
reference documentation that's needed if
you're familiar Point Blank we use that
for say
preconditions and then on the bottom we
have a URL to the connect page for that
PIN for that test co uh test plan that's
being used in here again for
traceability reasons on the right I'm
just showing that it is scheduled uh by
default for output uh once a
week and here is that multi-agent report
that I showed earlier again being shared
with the data
team now of course we want to know
what's happening when we execute these
tests and with Point Blank we show that
it integrates with
blastula so we wanted to again uh borrow
that concept and apply it to a test plan
so we're going to revisit our execute
test plan function again and all we're
going to look for is if any of the
individual agents in that test plan
failed if they failed I want you to send
me an email saying that it did with a
specific template even if it didn't fail
if nothing I I still want an email
telling me that it ran and it was
successful here's an example of what
that email looks like uh so your um
subject will have the number of cases
that failed this is an example of a
email with a failed test plan uh that
failed the time the test was run and a
textualized version of that multi-agent
report so originally we had the
multi-agent report coming through email
The Forum adding was a little wonky uh
and we realized it wasn't that
actionable for the team so this is what
we have coming to our
inboxes and lastly we wanted to enable
monitoring of everything that's going on
so you can imagine we have all of these
test plans being executed automatically
in a production setting and um we also
want to monitor the health of our uh
dashboards or I'm sorry we want to
monitor the health of all of our studies
and test plans that are being executed
uh the point of this is we want to drive
change Upstream to the engineers to the
study teams that are actually uh
creating these apps so in order to
monitor we need to save our validation
results first and so again let's revisit
execute test plan and we have this
pseudo code here save validation results
where when that runs it takes your
executed test plans and it passes them
through as a pin into our um cloud
storage buckets and then from there
we're actually extracting summary data
from these test plans uh that go into a
small database and that database is
powered in a shiny app that we've
created that helps us monitor what's
going on the health of all these
programs so we have some value boxes up
top telling us uh how many tests run
what's our failure rate this is all fake
data by the way uh what's our failure
rate uh and what are kind of the most
offensive tests the ones that are
failing the most we have a table of
everything that was run and also some
historical trends of uh failure rate to
see what's going uh what's improving or
what's
not and so in summary by addressing
these four um these four challenges we
were able to create that end to-end
scalable solution but really it wouldn't
have been possible with all the work
that came before us and so from a
medical perspective it was all those
data quality measures that we actually
used as the basis as the foundation for
these test plans in knowing what to
validate and in terms of our packages
and Technologies uh everything here
that's on the screen made this um all
possible and that's it thank you
thank you Michael um so what is uh what
was like the biggest challenge that you
all had in being able to set up all this
infrastructure uh we we had the
infrastructure with just the fact that
we automated data transfers uh it was um
one getting to the mindset of actually
making code to run the test instead of
doing it manually which which the whole
team had done but then also um our data
is pretty specific in terms of like how
the data is stored and what the column
name look like things like that things
that you kind of took for granted and
originally we tried to run point blank
on it we would get errors uh and so it's
just basically going into the source
code and just kind of picking apart what
we needed what we needed to change and
that's what took most of the time that
was the biggest challenge well thank you
again thank
you